We're really interested in solving this
temporal credit assignment problem as we will
see as we talk later on in the course. This sort of issue
comes up again and again and again. But, I didn't really want to talk
about that in any great detail, I just wanted to make certain that,
that people saw the difference between
supervised learning and then sort of problems
we're trying to solve now. That really has to do with sequences and
time. What I want to just is focus a little bit more on
rewards. And in particular, I want to look at the little grid world
that we've been playing with so far, and think about how
we would learn how to get from our start state. We
always start it over here, over to one of the plus
one or the minus 1, depending upon the kind of rewards
that we see. So, let's push on this rewards notion for
a minute, if we think about how MDP's are made up.
And I'm just going to write down for you what the
reward is, for the states in this particular grid world, okay?
>> Yeah.
>> So, let's say
I'm going to set the rewards to be equal to,
minus 0.04. So, the first thing I want to do, is
I want to make certain you understand what I mean
by this. So, what I mean when I write this
down, for this particular example. Is that the reward
that I'm going to receive in every single state is minus
0.04, except of course for these two states which
I've already labelled as plus 1 and minus 1. Okay?
>> Alright, so,
it seems like you should just never ever move then, right?
>> no, I don't think that's true. Let's think
about that for a little while. So, if I
set this reward to be minus 0.04 and you're
starting out here in this state, and you have
to keep living, you always have to take an
action, right? That's the way I've set this up.
And you don't get to stop until you reach
either plus 1 or negative 1, we'll call these
terminating or absorbing states. Once you reach
into one of these things that ends
the game. What would having a small
negative reward like, this encourage you to do?
>> It's, it's making me think about kind of walking across hot beach, because
like each time you take a step you're going to get a little bit of punishment
and the only thing that ends it is if you can get into that nice
cool ocean. And then you get a plus 1 for that and the minus 0.04s,
minus 0.04s, stop.
>> Right, so, that means, so wait how would
you put that another way. Sounds to me like
what you're saying is, by having a small negative
reward everywhere, it encourages you to end the game.
>> Yeah, that's [UNKNOWN]. Yeah, I agree with that.
>> Okay, yeah and, and I think that's exactly what I like
that analogy a lot. Your in a, well, it's not a very
hot beach it's just a you know, a slightly unpleasantly warm beach
and you really want to hurry up and get into the ocean.
In fact, you want to hurry up and get into the ocean
even though on your way to getting to the ocean. You might step
on some glass, that the minus 1 is. So, let's go back
to this notion of policy of mapping states to action and let's think
about as being in this world where you have a reward of
minus 0.04 every where except in the absorbing states. What do you think
the best set of actions are to take in these different states?
What do you think the best policy is? Actually before you tell me,
let me write down what the actual policy is. I'm not
going to tell you, how we get here but I'm about to
write down the policy that's sort of the best one to
take in a world where you have these sets of rewards. Okay.
>> Sure.
>> Okay, you see this Michael.
>> Yeah, and it makes a lot of sense. Like if
you're basically heading towards the, the rewarding state, the green state.
>> Right, so if I start out here in the leftmost bottom state, basically,
it says, go up and then go to the right which, coincidentally is the policy
that we had found before.
>> Cool. There's a couple spots that are a little bit strange, though.
>> Like what?
>> Well, I'm thinking about the one, not directly under the minus 1,
that makes sense to me, but the one, it takes you now to a
position. Where it seems like you want to go straight up to the goal.
But yet, it's going the long way around. It just didn't see the goal.
>> No that's not it at all because of the way we
are going to learn this, you're going to. So this is a global policy and
I'm just telling you it's the optimal policy given the
rewards. So let's kind of work out why going to
the left makes sense here. Well, so here's my argument.
What this basically says is take the long way around. Yes?
>> Yeah?
>> But, by taking the long way around, what's happening? Well, on
the downside I'm going to pick up a little bit of negative reward,
for a while, you know, one, two, three, four, five, six or
so which is something like negative
0.2, negative 0.3, something like that, right?
But, by doing this, I avoid every getting into
a state where it might fall into the negative 1.
>> Because it's, it's stochastic.
>> Right, it's exactly, so stochastic means
if I'm in this state here no matter
what I do I have som, if I go up I have some chance of
moving to the right and following into
the negative 1. It's a relatively low chance,
it's only 10%. But, it works out that moving from here to here, the probability
of me falling into here. Is to high compared to the sort of near impossibility
of me ending up falling into the minus 1, if I can follow this path.
>> Interesting, okay, I guess that makes sense, it's cool.
>> Which actually suggests sort of the point that
I want to make here which is, that minor changes to
your reward function actually matter. So, if we had
a slightly different reward here, say. Not minus 0.04 but
something else, you might find that some of these
decisions would be different. I think you can see that?
>> Hm. I mean at the level that I'm understanding it, it seems like if
it's zero, that then it's in no particular hurry. If
it's minus something big, then maybe it's in a bigger hurry. But,
I don't, yeah I don't see exactly what the difference is going to be.
>> Okay, so let's see if we can help you see the difference by
making you take a quiz.
>> Aha!